et on continue de parler de cette
proposition de loi controversée avec
martin mais chez un avocat pénaliste au
barreau de paris et membre du collectif
de défense des libertés publiques et
black rob brigade
bonjour martin méchins merci de répondre
à nos questions jean castex on vient de
retomber à saisir le conseil
constitutionnel votre réaction
jean castex peut saisir le conseil que
le sien de toute façon ils auraient été
saisis évidemment par les membres de
l'opposition parlementaire
c'est un affichage mais on espère
effectivement que le conseil
constitutionnel fera respecter les
principes fondamentaux et notamment le
respect de la liberté de la presse
en censurant cet article 24 justement
vous êtes avocat
l'article 24 a été amendée ce qui l'est
moins sujet à interprétation non je n'ai
pas du tout moi je faisais à
l'interprétation
j'ai même envie de dire qu'il est en
voir plus sujet à interprétation puisque
on nous rajoute la mention de du but
manifeste qui soit porté atteinte mais
il a le problème je ne sais pas comment
sera caractérisé ce but manifeste et la
difficulté c'est en réalité avant que ça
arrive devant un tribunal et devant un
juge
ce sont les policiers sur le terrain qui
vont décider si oui ou non le fait
d'être filmé à un moment donné peut être
éventuellement constitutifs de ce délit
parce que il ya évidemment toutes les
personnes qui filme en direct alors que
ce soit des journalistes professionnels
ou même des journalistes amateurs entre
guillemets qui font des directs sur
facebook sur d'autres d'autres
plateformes l'arsenal juridique il n'est
pas suffisamment fort pour qu'on soit
obligé de rajouter des lois comme ça
alors il est tout à fait tout à fait
suffisant puisqu'il existe en réalité
des délits qui permet d'ores et déjà de
sanctionner des diffusions
d'informations privées sur les réseaux
sociaux qui permettent de réprimer
éventuellement des appels
la commission de crimes ou délits ou là
ou éventuellement des menaces et donc
l'arsenal
il existe en réalité donc c'est vraiment
une proposition de loi qui est là pour
faire plaisir aux syndicats de police et
par contre qui est extrêmement dangereux
pour la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'informer c'est toi est ce qu
elle vous paraît plus applicable que les
autres en matière de lutte contre la
haine en ligne justement vous parlez de
de cela non en fait le problème c'est
que et sera pas applicable devant les
tribunaux parce qu'ils ont en réalité il
est extrêmement rare d'avoir des
diffusions sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ont pour but manifeste de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité physique ou
psychique et des fonctionnaires de
police ou gendarmerie est d'ailleurs le
gouvernement est bien incapable de
donner des exemples
deux policiers de gendarmes qui aurait
été pris à partie ou menacés ou
violenter à la suite de ceux de ce type
de diffusion
donc non en réalité ça n'est pas
applicable
ça n'est pas viable devant les fabliaux
par contre ça sera applicable par les
policiers eux mêmes sur le terrain qui
pourront quand ils verront quelques uns
des films et dire eh bien écoutez
arrêter de fumer parce que peut-être que
vous êtes en train de diffuser en direct
et donc c'est un délit et donc on peut
vous interpeller vous placé en garde à
vue et vous empêcher de filmer ou quand
on nous dit que c'est un interdit patine
mais bien sûr que si parce que ça laisse
la liberté totale aux policiers sur le
terrain et aux gendarmes sur le terrain
d'empêcher des gens filmés dernière
question pourquoi est ce que cette loi
bénéficie d'une procédure accélérée on
le rappelle le fait qu'un projet de loi
ne fassent l'objet que d'une lecture par
chambre du parlement assemblée nationale
et du sénat avant d'être adoptée au lieu
de deux
moi j'ai envie de dire que c'est le mode
de fonctionnement de notre gouvernement
depuis quelques danses et de passer des
lois au forceps très rapidement pour que
finalement personne n'est le temps d
agir ou personne n'étant de de faire le
nécessaire pour s'opposer alors là en
l'occurrence sur ce projet de loi il ya
un vrai combat qui est mené
bhl qui est inconstant et qui surtout
est menée par de très nombreuses
associations des syndicats journaliste
est en réalité quasiment l'intégralité
des journalistes de terrain
merci martin méchant d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat pénaliste au barreau de paris et
membre du collectif de défense des
libertés publiques blacks jerome brigade